The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, then,
I guess we may as well start.
So what I wanted
to talk about today
was natural sandwich
panels and sandwich beams.
So there's lots of examples of
sandwich structures in nature,
and we've been looking at
the engineering sandwich
structures.
And we've seen that you can
get a lightweight structure
by having this
sandwich construction.
And so there are
several examples
I was going to talk about today.
And I think because this
isn't really on the test,
I'm not going to write
a lot on the board.
So there's some notes.
I'll just put them
on the website,
and you can look at
that if you want.
Because we have kind of
a shorter time today.
I'll just try and talk
and explain what's what.
Hey, Bruno.
How are you?
So this is the first example.
So many leaves of
Monocotyledon plants
have a sandwich structure.
And this is an iris
plant and iris leaves.
And for those of
you in 3032, I think
you know that these
are glass flowers.
So the Harvard Museum
of Natural History
has a glass flower collection
that was made in the 1800s.
And there was a
botany professor there
who made these as sort of a
lecture demonstration vehicle.
And so he would
bring then to class,
and he would show
different things
about the plants with
the glass flowers.
But now they're
just in the museum,
and they're very realistic.
So I just wanted
to show you those.
So let's see, it's not working.
Turn it on.
There we go.
So if we look at a
cross-section of an iris leaf,
it looks like the
diagram on the left.
So here's the iris.
And you can see there's
these kind of solid fibers,
and those solid fibers
are called schlerchyma.
And they only exist at the top
and the bottom of the leaf.
So I went out this morning.
And if you look outside
of the Stata building,
there's that little
kind of river-y thing,
and there's some iris
leaves growing there.
So I went and got
some iris leaves.
And you can tell we had a
horrible winter because usually
when I give this
lecture in the spring,
the leaves are
like twice as big.
But this year, they're just
little, short, wimpy ones.
But I'm going to pass it around.
And if you just like move
your thumb over the top,
you can feel little
ridges, little bumps.
And those little ridges
that you can feel
are these little
schlerchyma fibers.
So you kind of see they
kind of stick up a little.
And so when you move your thumb
over it, you can feel that.
And then you can see that
the middle of the iris leaf
has this kind of
foamy-type structure here,
and that's called
parenchyma cells.
So you can think of the
leaf as very much like one
of the sandwiches.
This is like a fiber-reinforced
composite at the top
and at the bottom.
And then this is kind of
like a foam core in between,
separating the
fiber-reinforced faces.
And so the iris leaf
behaves mechanically
like a sandwich beam.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about how we can actually
demonstrate that using the
equations that we developed
in class.
This is another example.
This is, I guess, what
Americans call the cat tail,
but Canadians and English
people call it a bull rush.
And you can see this
is a slightly different
construction, but there's
the same sort of idea.
So instead of having a foamy
core as in the iris leaf,
you've got these
kind of webs here
that go in between the
top and the bottom,
and that forms like a
series of I-beams almost.
And you can think of
that also like a sandwich
panel or a sandwich beam.
So you've got two stiff
top and bottom pieces,
and then you've got these kind
of webs that separate them,
kind of like a
honeycomb core would be.
So that's another example
of a leaf that has
the sandwich-type structure.
And this is very common in
these Monocotyledon leaves.
So if you think of a cat
tail or you think of an iris,
they tend to be kind
of narrow at the base,
maybe an inch or two
wide at the base,
and they can be quite tall.
The iris leaves can get
two or three feet tall.
The cat tails can get
five or six feet tall.
And they stand up
more or less straight.
They bend over a little, but
they stand up more or less
straight.
And this sandwich
structure is one
of the things that lets
them stand up straight
at a fairly low weight.
And from the plant's
point of view,
there's a sort of
metabolic cost associated
with making more material.
So it we can minimize
the amount of material,
it's a better thing
for the plant.
These are some other
examples of grasses that are
sandwich-type constructions.
This is from some papers
by Julian Vincent.
And the black little circles
here are the schlerchyma,
are those sort of dense fibers.
Then you can see in
both of these cases,
the dense fibers
are on the outside,
and the parenchyma cells,
which is the white,
are on the inside.
And so this is sort of another
set of micrographs of the iris.
So this is just
showing the outside,
and these are the ribs
viewed from the outside.
And this is the core,
just sort of viewed
along the length of it.
And so you can
idealize the structure
as being like a sandwich that's
got sort of fibers on the top
and on the bottom.
So the top and the bottom
are like a fiber composite.
And the middle part, with
the parenchyma cells,
is kind of like a foam.
And so we did a little
project on iris leaves,
and we wanted to
see if you could
show that they
behave mechanically,
like a sandwich beam.
So you remember that we had
that equation for the deflection
of the sandwich beam.
There were two terms.
There was a bending term, and
then there was a shearing term.
And so we took some
little sandwich beams.
We cut little kind
of rectangular beams.
We hung little weights.
We measured how
much they deflected,
and we wanted to see if
we could use this equation
to predict their stiffness
and how much they deflected.
So to do that, we needed
to know a bunch of things.
We needed to know some of
the geometrical parameters.
So we needed to know what
volume fraction of the face
is those solid ribs, how thick's
the core, how thick's the face?
And so we measured a bunch of
these geometrical parameters.
We tested it like a cantilever
so we knew what B1 and B2 were
for the cantilever.
We knew how long the beam
was, so we know what l is.
We knew what loads we applied,
so we knew what P was.
But we needed to
make some estimate
of what the face modulus
was and what the core shear
modulus was, too.
And so we made some
estimates of that.
So this table here
just shows some
of the dimensions of the leaf.
The leaf tapers, and
this is at the thin end,
so here's the face thickness.
Here's the sort
of length of this.
Some square cells in the face.
This is the core thickness here.
This is the dimensions
of the core cells.
This is the diameter of the
ribs, the spacing of the ribs,
the volume fraction
of solids in the ribs.
And we did that at
different lengths
along the different positions
along the length of the rib,
or length of the leaf.
So we had the
geometrical parameters,
but we needed to get this E
of the face and G of the core.
And to do that, we
looked at the literature.
And people had done tests on
the fiber parts of leaves.
They'd done little
tensile tests,
and they'd measured
modulii between about two
and 20 gigapascals.
And then we did some tension
tests on the iris leaf.
And in tension,
those ribs are going
to take most of the stress.
And if you know the volume
fraction of the ribs,
you can back out what
the stiffness of the ribs
must have been.
If you know the
stiffness of the ribs,
you can figure out the
stiffness of the face.
So we calculated that, and then
we looked at the literature.
And people have done
tests on parenchyma cells
and different types of tissue on
things like apples and potatoes
and carrots.
And these are the values for
the Young's modulus they get.
They're between about 1, and the
highest one was 14 megapascals.
But most of these values
for the Young's modulus
are around about four.
And the shear modulus
is roughly about half
of the Young's modulus.
So we said the shear
modulus was around two.
So we have these values we could
plug it in and then calculate
what the stiffness would
be for the iris leaf.
And so this was a
little analysis we did.
So this was the measured
beam stiffness up here.
We had four beams, and they
were different stiffnesses.
They all had the same length.
They all the same
face thickness.
The core thickness varied.
They all had the same width.
We cut them to have the
same width so we could
calculate a flexural rigidity.
That's the EI equivalent.
We could calculate the bending
deflection term, the shear
deflection term.
And this is the
calculated beam stiffness.
And then this is the
ratio of the calculated
over the measured.
So it's not exactly right.
Obviously, there's
some difference here.
But it's in the same
order of magnitude.
It's in the same ballpark.
And one of the complications
that we didn't really
try to take into account
was that the leaf isn't
a nice rectangular structure.
The leaf has this kind of
curved cross-section to it.
And we made a bit of an
approximation to that,
but it wasn't that
close, really.
We could have probably
done better on that.
But I think the idea that the
iris behaves like a sandwich is
a reasonable one.
So that was the iris leaf.
And then I wanted to show you
some other structures in nature
that are sandwiches.
So this is a seakelp,
help like a seaweed thing,
in New Zealand.
This is the largest
intertidal seaweed.
The fronds, the sort
of long pieces of it,
are up to 12 meters long.
So that's almost 40 feet.
So 40 feet is probably like
from one side of this room
to the other side of the room.
It's quite long.
And you can see, if you
look at this section here,
this is all like a
honeycomb-type section here.
And the honeycomb is like
a honeycomb in a sandwich,
and the top and the
bottom faces are
like the face of the sandwich.
So this would be
like the face here.
That would be the
honeycomb core.
And that would be the other face
on the other side over there.
And those honeycomb-like
cores, apparently,
have some gas-filled pockets
that then provide buoyancy
to keep the whole
thing floating.
So it photosynthesizes.
So one of the things
about these leaves
is that they have
multiple functions.
It's not just that they have
to have a certain stiffness
so they don't fall over.
The plant wants to
photosynthesize,
so you want to maximize
the surface area as well,
and you want to have
exposure to the sunlight.
So there's a number of things
that the plant's trying
to do in having this structure.
So that seakelp is one example.
These are skulls from birds.
And so this is a pigeon here.
This is a magpie.
If you come from the West
you see magpies out West.
You see them in Europe as well.
And this is a long-eared owl.
This long-eared
owl's around here.
And I brought in a couple
of bird skulls as well.
And you can see that all
of those birds skulls
are sandwich structures.
The one for the pigeon has
sort of a foam-like core here.
And you can see
that the two faces
aren't sort of concentric
for the pigeon skull.
They sort of not
following each other.
But here, this would be,
say, on the top shell
of the magpie, where the two,
the inner and outer face,
are sort of concentric.
Then you get these kind of
little ribs of trabecular bone
in between them, and then the
same with a long-eared owl.
You get these little
ribs in between them.
And so you can see that there's
a sandwich structure there.
And obviously, birds
want to be light.
They have to be light
to fly, to take off,
and so they want to be light.
So I've got two skulls here.
And I'll pass them around.
Please be careful because
they're kind of delicate.
This one is from a screech
owl, and you see screech owls
around here.
This was a screech owl that
had an intersection with a car.
Yeah, so the skull fractured,
but you can see the sandwich
right there.
You see the two little bits?
So you can see the inner
plate and the outer plate
and the foam, the
trabecular bone.
So that's the screech owl.
And this is a red tail hawk.
So you can't really see
the shell and the sandwich
structure here.
But I want to pass
it around just
so you can see how light it is.
So it's amazingly light.
So a red tail hawk is
probably about this big,
something like that.
And this is one of the things
that makes them very light.
So those are the bird skulls.
Oh, yes, so now I have to
tell you about the owl.
So I think the people in
3032 have heard this before.
But the other people haven't.
So one of the
things about the owl
is if you look at
the whole skull,
if you look at this picture
here, one of the things
is that this bone here is not
symmetrical with that bone
there.
Normally, when you
think of a body,
you think of the bones
being symmetrical.
But those bones are
not symmetrical,
and those bones are
near where the ear is.
And it turns out on owls,
at least on some owls,
the ears are at different
heights on their heads.
And people think that
one of the things that
allows the owls to do is
it allows their hearing
to sort of pinpoint
where something is.
And owls can catch little
creatures at night,
but they can also catch little
creatures underneath the snow.
So they can catch things
that they can't even see.
And they have a
number of adaptations
to improve their hearing,
but this is one of them.
So here's a little owl Allison
Curtis is a Canadian friend who
lives in northern Ontario,
and this is looking out
of her living room window.
And that's a barred owl.
And you can see
the barred owl has
caught this little vole here.
And you can see
in the background
it's winter in Canada.
and there's snow
all over the place.
So this owl has probably
caught that little vole
underneath the snow.
And then it's come to eat it.
And this is another
picture of-- you
can see this is where an
owl landed in the snow.
It's wings hit the snow, trying
to catch something underneath.
And this is another
kind of beautiful print
of the owl's wings hitting
the snow in the winter time.
So did I show you the fox video?
Should I show you the fox video?
You saw it, right?
I think I showed it
last time in 3032.
But you guys haven't seen it.
Let me show you the
fox video because foxes
do the same kind of thing.
Their ears are the same as ours.
They're in the same position.
But they have this-- let me see.
Where's the sound thing?
We don't really need
the sound for this,
but there's BBC sound.
So we get this music,
even though the fox
can't hear the music.
Here we go, fox no drive.
Check this out.
Is it going to come up?
Is that going to play?
OK
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-It listens for the tiny sounds
of its prey moving about below.
PROFESSOR: So you see
how it cocks its head,
and it does this with its head?
It's putting its ears
at different heights
when it does that.
So check this out.
And look carefully, you
can see the little animal
it's got in its mouth
when it comes out.
There's a little tail.
So part of the reason
dogs and foxes and coyotes
do that thing, I
think, is because they
put their ears at
different heights,
and it helps them pinpoint
where something is.
[END PLAYBACK]
You know I love these
Nature videos, right?
So that's the fox video.
Let me see if I can stop that.
So that's one of the
interesting things about owls.
Let me go back to my
little PowerPoints.
So here's another example
of a creature that
has a sandwich-type structures.
So here's the sandwich here.
Here is the ever so
charming looking cuttlefish.
And the cuttlefish is
not actually a fish.
It's a mollusk.
So it's related to things like
octopus, things like that,
and squids.
It's a cephalopod.
And you can't see it so
well in this picture,
but I'm going to show you
something else and you see it.
It's got like little tentacles.
These things here are actually
separate little tentacles.
And because it's not a fish,
it doesn't have like fins
that can kind of swim with.
And it's got this thing
called the cuttlefish bone.
And this is a
cuttlefish bone here.
And that bone has the
sandwich structure here.
And it's not actually a bone.
It's really a shell.
It's a calcium carbonate thing,
not a calcium phosphate thing.
But the cuttlefish can
control how much air
goes into those little pockets.
And it can control its buoyancy
by controlling how much air
goes into those little pockets.
And I brought with
me a cuttlefish bone.
Have you ever owned
like, I don't know,
like a parrot or a pet bird?
Apparently, pet birds love
to sharpen their beaks
on this cuttlefish bone.
So if you go to a pet store,
you can buy this stuff.
So you won't be able to
see the little sandwich
structure because it's a
very small length scale.
But you can kind of
see there's a sort
of different material
on the inside
than there is on
the outside of that.
So do people know
the other thing
that cuttlefish are famous
for, besides the bone?
Change colors.
Can I show you a video of
cuttlefish changing color?
Yeah, of course.
So let me get rid of this again.
Go back to this.
Let's see, somewhere--
where's the cuttlefish?
Here we go.
Did I do it?
Is it thinking?
Here we go.
Where's the cuttlefish?
So this is another one
of these Science Friday
videos from National Public
Radio with Flora Lichtman.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-OK, let's play a game.
[GAME SHOW MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: See it?
-Biologist Sarah Zielinski
took these shots.
And if you needed a helping
hand to find the cuttlefish,
don't feel bad.
-I've certainly taken photos
in the past then come back
to look at them and gone, I'm
sure there was a cuttlefish
in there somewhere!
-These cephalopods are
master camouflagers.
But while they're
hiding their body,
they're revealing
something about their mind,
or at least their visual system.
-In very simple terms,
they can tell us
what they can see by
the body patterns they
produce on their skin.
-They produce
these body patterns
by expanding or
contracting chromatophores,
these little ink
sacks on their skin.
And they use different
displays for different reasons,
like for male-to-male combat.
-Two males will
turn into each other
and pass these kind of
waves of dark chromatophores
over a really bright sort of
iridescent stripey body pattern
and somehow solve these combats.
Eventually, one male
gives up and goes away.
-And then there's
this unsolved mystery.
It changes color when
it grabs a snack.
-That doesn't make perfect
sense because it seems
to make it very conspicuous.
So one theory is that
it's just a happy signal
of how excited it
is to have caught
something, some response that it
doesn't have any control over.
-But most of the
time they seem to be
using their chromatophores
more intentionally,
primarily to blend in.
-Because otherwise they're
more likely to be eaten,
so it's very important
they don't make mistakes
about ambiguous
visual information.
-And ambiguous
visual information
is specifically what
Zielinski's interested in.
So here's the
experimental setup.
Print out laminated patterns,
like this checkerboard,
and stick them in a tank.
-And we place the
animals in the tank.
And we record the body
patterns that they produce.
-You're seeing them on squares,
but they do the same thing
on top of circles.
They produce--
- --the disruptive pattern,
where you get these blocky
components of
high-contrast components.
-But when you put a cuttlefish
over squiggles, it produces--
- --a sort of mottley pattern,
where you get these little
groups of dark spots
showing across the body.
-So what happens when you
put a cuttlefish on something
in between, when you put
them on incomplete circles?
When we see something like
this, our visual system
likes to fill in the blanks,
something we do constantly,
Zielinski says.
-The reason why cartoons
and sketches work
is because we can
recognize objects
based on their edges alone.
-And we can identify objects
even if they're broken up or--
- --have an object that is
occluded by another object.
That's no problem for us.
We can still work out what the
object is most of the time.
And I was interested to
know whether cuttlefish
can solve similar problems.
-And Zielinski and colleagues
report this week that
cuttlefish do seem to--
- --fill in those gaps and
interpret those little segments
as a whole circle.
-Or anyway, the broken circles
prompted the same camo pattern
as full circles.
So if you're wondering, uh,
I see these as circles, too.
What's the big deal?
The weird thing here is
that there's no reason why
cuttlefish, which are--
- --invertebrates, and they're
in the same group as slugs
and snails.
- --should see the
world the way we do.
-Yes, it's like they're
alien, but we also
seem to have so much
in common with them.
-So the next step?
-Because we can't share
the perceptive experience
of a cuttlefish,
it's hard to know
exactly what it is that they're
doing to fill in that missing
information.
And I want to try to get
a better grasp on that
and also see whether
they actually respond
to true illusory contours.
-So you're going to show
optical illusions to cuttlefish?
-(LAUGHING) That's what
I'm hoping to do, yes.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So let's
go back to sandwiches.
I think I have--
do I have one more?
There we go.
So horseshoe crab shells,
so different sorts
of arthropods, the shells
are sandwiched too.
This is from Mark Myers' work.
So we're looking at
the cross-section
of a horseshoe crab shell.
So again, it's the same
idea-- the animal wants
to minimize the
amount of material
or minimize the weight, and
this is a way of doing that.
And I went to the
Galapagos about a year ago.
And there was a place where
they had these giant Galapagos
tortoise shells.
And one of them
was broken, and you
could see there was a sandwich
structure in the Galapagos
tortoise shells.
These Galapagos tortoises,
their shell is like this big.
They're gigantic.
They're huge.
So those are my examples of
sandwich panels and beams
and shells and
whatnot in nature.
So the idea is that
nature too wants
to minimize weight and minimize
the amount of material,
and the sandwich structure
is a way of doing that.
So I have one more thing I
wanted to talk about today.
So this isn't quite
sandwich structures,
but it's looking at another
kind of natural structure
that is designed to reduce
the weight of plant stems,
in this case, palm stems.
And there's a couple of
interesting things about this.
So when you look at
palms, like let's pretend
we're not in Boston.
We're in California,
where they have palms.
And we're in LA, and
they don't have winter.
And if you look at the palms
growing, when the palm's short,
it's about this big in diameter.
And as it gets
taller and taller,
the diameter doesn't
really change.
It gets taller and
taller and taller,
but the diameter doesn't change,
at least in some species.
Whereas if you think
of a tree, a tree
starts out with a
little skinny diameter.
And as the tree gets taller,
the diameter gets bigger.
And it sort of tapers and
does that whole thing.
So palms don't do that.
And palms are not trees.
They're a botanically
different thing from trees.
So here's a coconut palm.
And so the question is, as the
stem gets taller and taller,
how does it resist
the bending loads that
get bigger and bigger?
So probably, the main load
on these sorts of things
is from the wind.
And often these
plants are in areas
where they have hurricanes.
And you see them
in hurricanes, you
see the pictures of the
palm stem blowing way over.
And so how do they resist
the larger internal stresses
as they get taller and taller,
if the diameter doesn't
get bigger and bigger?
And the way they do that is that
they deposit additional layers
of cell wall as the plant ages.
So if you think of a
tree, when a tree grows,
it just deposits
more and more cells.
And the cells have roughly
the same thickness.
So there's ones that are
deposited in the spring have
thinner walls.
Then the summer and the
fall have thicker walls.
But more or less, it's similar.
Whereas the palm,
it deposit cells,
and then as the
trunk of the palm
gets taller, as the
stem gets taller,
it deposits more layers
on the cell wall.
So this is an example in an SCM.
You can see here
this is a young cell,
and it's got-- this one that's
not marked is a primary cell
wall, and then this is the first
layer of the secondary cell
wall.
And then this is an older palm.
And you can see here
it's got more layers,
and so the cell wall
itself has gotten thicker.
So that means that the
density of the tissue
changes as the palm ages.
And it does so in a
very kind of clever way.
If you think of the palm as
being like a cantilever that's
vertical and it's bending in the
wind, when we have a cantilever
beam or any kind of
beam, the stresses
are going to be biggest
on the periphery, right?
They're going to be
biggest on the outside.
And if you think of
the palm as having
a circular cross-section,
that outer periphery
is going to see the
biggest stresses.
So it would make the most sense
if that was the densest tissue.
And that's exactly
what the palm does.
So there was a nice study
done by Paul Rich quite
a number of years ago.
And he studied palms
in Central America
and looked at the
density and measured
the mechanical properties.
And I'm going to talk
about his stuff today.
So the white is the low density.
The gray's the medium,
and the black's the high.
So you can see the low
density's on the middle
of the young stem, and
just at the very base
and then the periphery
is the dense tissue.
But as the stem gets
taller and gets older,
then stuff that was low
density is now high density.
And only the very middle
here is the low density.
And that some stuff
that was low density
has turned to middle density.
And some stuff that
was low density
has turned to high density.
So it's done this by adding
more and more layers to the cell
wall, making the
cell wall thicker
and making the cells
themselves denser.
So this is looking
just at a single palm.
So each one of these
lines is a single palm.
And this is looking at
how the density changes
from the periphery to
the center of the palm.
So if you cut the
palm down and, say,
we take a little sample radially
from the middle to the outside
or from the outside
to the middle,
he then measured the density.
And it's probably easiest
to think about the dry ones
because that's kind of what
you would compare wood to.
So the dry densities varied
from about one gram per CC,
that's about 1,000
kilograms per cubic meter,
down to almost zero in
this particular species
here, probably like 50
or something like that.
And if you compare
this with woods,
this little arrow here is the
density of most common woods.
So if you looked at pine
and spruce an oak and maple
and ash and hickory, they would
all be in that little range
there.
So a single palm stem
can have a bigger range
of densities than many
different species of wood.
So it has this kind of
profile of the density.
And the thing I
was interested in
is seeing how
mechanically efficient
that was to put the denser
material at the outside.
So I looked at the
stiffness of the palm,
and I also looked
at the strength.
So I just replotted that data
on this slightly different axes
here.
So this is the radial position
relative to the outer radius,
and this is the density.
And I subtracted off the
minimum and then took the range.
And for this species
here, the minimum density
was almost zero.
So this expression simplifies
to something like that.
And just because it's
mathematically simpler,
that's what we're
going to look at.
So the density goes roughly
as the radius squared.
And Paul Rich also did a lot of
mechanical tests on the palm,
and he took out little beams
of different densities.
And he measured the stiffness
and the strength of the beams.
So he measured the modulus of
elasticity here versus density.
And he measured the
modulus of rupture here.
And these are all
along the grain.
And he found that the Young's
modulus varied with the density
to the 2.5 power,
and the strength
varied as the density squared.
And if the--
[BUZZING SOUND]
Oh, hello.
[LAUGHTER]
So these were just sorts
of empirical findings
that he made.
If you have prismatic cells
and you deform them axially,
and the cell wall was the same
in the different specimens,
then the solid modulus
would be a constant.
And you would expect that
the modulus of the beam
would go just linearly
with the density, sort
of like a honeycomb
loaded [? at a ?] plane.
But what he measured was that
the modulus and the strength
varied with some
power of the density.
And the reason for
that really was
that the cell walls
of the denser material
had more layers.
And in the additional layers,
the cellulose microfibular
angle was probably different,
so that the different layers
had different stiffnesses.
And if you have
layers of differences,
then you're going to get
this power relationship.
So what I then did
was I took his data,
and I tried to see how efficient
that would be in bending.
So he had found that the density
varied with the radius raised
to some power.
This power n was 2, but
I wanted to do it just
for a general case, so
I said I was just n.
And he said that he found
that the modulus varied
with the density raised
to some other power m.
And for him, m was 2 and 1/2.
And so I could write
just another equation
saying that the modulus goes
as the radius to the mn power.
And then you could do
a little calculation
where you work out with the
equivalent flexural rigidity
is.
So you have to integrate up.
You kind of say you
have a little band
at a certain radius.
That radius has a
certain modulus.
And you can figure out
the moment of inertia
that goes with that
particular radius.
And then if you integrate
it up over the whole thing,
you can say that the
flexural rigidity
for the gradient density
is some constant times
pi times the outer radius
to the fourth power divided
by those two powers mn plus 4.
So m was the power
here for the modulus.
And n was the power
there for the density.
And then you could compare
that with having the same mass
just uniformly distributed
over the whole cross-section.
And then if you take the
ratio of the flexural rigidity
for the density gradient
versus the flexural rigidity
for the uniform
density, you can show
that it's this equation here.
And then if you plug in
these measured values
for those exponents
for n and m, you
find that the flexural rigidity
with the gradient density
relative to the uniform density
is a factor of 2 and 1/2.
So the stem is 2 and
1/2 times stiffer
by having that density profile.
So there's a huge sort
of mechanical advantage
to doing that.
And just sort of
physically, if you
know the stresses our
biggest on the outside,
it would make sense to put the
denser material on the outside.
And then the other
thing I looked at
was the strength of the palm.
So imagine this is our
very schematic palm here,
and then there's a
circular cross section.
So I wanted to compare the
bending stress distribution
with the bending
strength distribution.
So the stress goes as the
modulus times the strain,
just Hooke's law.
And here we're assuming that
plane sections remain plane,
like that's the standard
assumption of bending.
So if you assume plane
sections remain plane,
then the strain goes with the
curvature times the distance y
from the neutral axis, the
distance from the middle.
So this distance here would
be the dis-- [? same ?]
at loaded with a loaded p here.
That distance would be y there.
And then I can plug
in some things here.
So instead of E, I'm going
to plug-in my relationship
with the radius
to that mn power.
And here's my curvature,
and instead of y,
if I say that some
radius, I'm going
to say y is our r cos theta.
And so I'm going to say
that the stress goes--
[SNEEZE]
Bless you.
Goes as radius raised
to some power mn plus 1.
And again, for the species
I know what n and m are,
so the stress goes as the
radius to the sixth power.
And then I can also compare
with what Paul Rich had
found for the strength.
He found that the strength--
so sigma star is the strength--
was proportional to the
density raised to some power q,
and that power was 2 in the
measurements that he made.
And so I can say
that the strength
goes as the radius to this power
nq, so to the fourth power.
And then if I plot the stress
distribution and the strength
distribution-- so imagine, this
is through the cross-section
here.
So this is the
diameter of the stem.
And this is the neutral
axis here in the middle.
The strength goes as
that solid line there.
It goes as the fourth power.
And the stress goes as
that dashed line there,
as the sixth power.
So they're not exactly
on top of each other,
but they're very close to
being on top of each other.
So basically what
the palm has done
is it's arranged the
material in such a way
that the strength
matches the stresses that
are applied to it.
So if I just had a
constant density,
my stress profile
would look like that.
And if I had a constant
density, the strength profile
would kind of like that.
So the strength here
would be a constant,
and this would be
the stress here.
So the stuff in the
middle, it's much stronger
than it needs to be.
Whereas the palm has arranged
things so that it's got
just the right amount of
strength for the stress,
as a function of
the radial position.
So it's kind of a clever thing.
So that's kind of
a beautiful thing.
And I think that is it.
I think that's-- yeah,
that's the end of it.
So all these images came from
this other book that we wrote.
And if you wanted
to get the sources,
you could get them from there.
So that all I wanted
to talk about today
was some examples of sort of
efficient mechanical design
in nature and the sandwich
panel structures as one,
and these radial density
gradients is another.
We have a project
on bamboo right now,
and the bamboo also has a
radial density gradient,
and it's the same thing.
The densest material's
on the outside,
and the least dense
is on the inside.
So I think I'm going to
stop there for today.
So what I was going
to do on Monday
is talk a little bit
about bio-mimicking.
And that won't take
the whole class at all.
And I thought we could
spend the rest of the class
on Monday just doing a review.
So the test's on Wednesday.
So if you want to
bring questions,
that would be a beautiful thing.
I can't really can I review
the whole last six weeks
or something in an hour
and a half or something.
So if you want to bring
questions, I'll be here
and we can just
go over questions.
Does that sound good?